all right
um I'm going to uh
open the proceedings of the house
Judiciary Committee and we will begin
with the Pledge of Allegiance
of America
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
right
um
so we have a hearing on
Senate Bill 128 and in particular the
non-germaine Amendment
um
2023 1482 which I sponsored and I I
guess I should say
um
that
the non-germane
non-germannness of this amendment
pertains only to section two of the bill
which is what the section that proposes
to add a new
uh
term to a new section to RSA 604-a
that is the is the new uh Amendment
and I should
I should note that um
there is
an alternative to my amendment that
um has been uh proposed by
representative Smith which
is the same as my Amendment except that
it doesn't include
section two
um
and as I've said to her and I really say
to to the other members of the of the
committee and also to the public I
I don't really think I have any problem
if it turns out that there's a that
there that people feel that we shouldn't
go ahead and go forward with section two
at this time
um but only section one I I very likely
would be willing to withdraw my
amendment in favor of Representative
Smith's Amendment but nonetheless since
we scheduled a hearing on it and since I
do I actually do think and I'll tell you
in a minute why since section two has
some value
um I I would at least like to explore
um going forward with with Maya men
um yes representative Smith
uh thank you
um Mr chair let me just respond to what
you said before we go on because I think
it's it's relevant
um if if you were not on this committee
and your understanding of what this
committee is to do this morning was
based on the official House calendar
that came out Thursday night
it says relative to payment for legal
services for persons involuntarily
admitted for mental health services the
amendment establishes the payment of
legal services for Indigent and
non-indigent individuals involuntarily
committed for mental health services as
well as the process to determine such
indigency and repayment for such
Services that's what it says so no one
except those people in the know
would have any idea
about part two of the amendment because
the the calendar does not even
acknowledge it so to begin with I have
problems that way with house bill with
with your amendment I do want to say
that although I have notified the
committee of the possibility of my
um introducing an amendment out of
courtesy and we haven't discussed it at
all certainly because of 91a
I personally don't like my amendment I
think for
a lot of reasons
um it's it's
not good I would prefer to go with just
the bill but out of respect for the
chair of the committee and out of my
commitment always to try to find
compromise I do have that amendment that
I haven't yet distributed
um seen how the committee feels that
might I would then bring it forward as
an alternative so um I you know I thank
you for
um beginning the way you did which made
it possible for us to kind of get a
sense of the lay of the land sure sure
no no that's fine and I guess you know I
I guess what I would say is um on the on
the notice I mean I I don't I don't
particularly disagree with with the the
fact that the notice probably could have
been better than it was uh but on the
other hand it does refer to the
amendment and so somebody in the
somebody that was was interested in this
and wanted to pick up the amendment
could have picked up the amendment and
read it and would would be informed so
um anyway I guess I would what I would
say
um with with regard to this is with
regard to section two and I'm glad that
um uh judge king is here from the uh
from the circuit court because I think
he can uh he may be able to uh confirm
my recollection of this but
one of the things and also uh uh uh the
representative from the judicial Council
one of the things that I can remember
over a number of years being involved in
the court system is there were a number
of occasions on which
there would a question would come up
as to paying for counsel or for other
services ins in one context or another
and
as as some of you may or may not have
some of you may not be aware but there's
a statute it's RSA
490 31.
which basically says if a question if
there's a
if if the court uh directs that some
services including legal service
Services be provided and it's unclear
who pays the court pays and so
um uh that means that the the monies
come out of the Court's budget as
opposed to the judicial council's budget
or some some other uh entity DHHS or
whatever budget
um and that was often a source of a fair
amount of frustration in the court
saying why you know this really ought to
be this really ought to come out of the
judicial Council budget so the purpose
of section two
was essentially to create
a a catch-all
provision that says
if
if there's any circumstance in which
either the Constitution or a state
statute
grants a right to council to an
individual
um who uh and provides that the person
has a right to uh that if Indigent the
person has a right to appointed counsel
um and then then Council would be paid
in those circumstances from the judicial
Council and there would be and that
would be subject to reimbursement in the
same way that uh reimbursement is is uh
allowed under 604a for Council in uh in
juvenile cases or criminal cases that
kind of thing I just thought that that
made that was a good housekeeping
Amendment so to speak that
um that uh basically
consolidates if you will that all uh
payments for Council and related
services in these kinds of cases is to
be paid
um out of uh funds for the judicial
Council
um I guess I would note because I'm sure
Mr sample will have has very legitimate
concerns on this that there are
obviously there are some financial
implications for the judicial Council
about that and I would note in that
regard that this bill is is on a fast
track because the next place it goes if
it passes is to finance
um where
um presumably they can deal with those
uh with those issues I'm certainly
sympathetic to uh to uh
Mr samples uh
what I anticipate would be his concerns
on this so that's uh with that I guess I
will uh
open the hearing and I would uh first
recognize uh Karen Rosenberg
good morning I'm Karen Rosenberg I'm the
policy director at the disability rights
Center and I'm here to strongly
encourage you to oppose the non-germaine
proposed amendment and to recommend
autopass as amended by the Senate on SB
128. and the reason for this is that
when we're talking about right to
counsel and these kinds of circumstances
when someone's subjected to an iea it's
much different from a criminal
proceeding where there's a right to
counsel
VES instead of using initials could you
I'm sorry an involuntary emergency
admission or an emergency or an
involuntary admission to a hospital what
we're talking about here are people who
have a really profound and serious
underlying mental illness who are in
crisis
and as a result of this underlying
mental illness and crisis that they are
in they are believed to be a danger to
themselves most frequently or perhaps
other people but most frequently what we
hear is that it's someone who's actively
suicidal
they're brought in by police treated as
criminals even though they're not
criminals this is non-volitional this is
something that occurs because of an
underlying mental illness they're
brought into an emergency room where
they are warehoused there's a
determination made by a doctor that this
should move forward so that they are
held there
Liberty removed for three days it's
usually around three days they have to
have a hearing before a court at that
point and then a judge would make a
decision about whether there's probable
cause to involuntarily admit them to the
mental health system
and in this process because we are
removing someone's Liberty our law
provides for the appointment of counsel
that's an absolute right and it also
makes it really difficult to waive
counsel which is not exactly like a
criminal proceeding either so what the
current law says is that a court would
have to make a finding that someone made
an informed decision if they were going
to waive Council so we've got person
mentally serious mental illness
is dangerous mostly to themselves
it's not volitional you know we don't
have charges here pending criminal
charges they are appointed an attorney
because they have in fact lost their
Liberty they're being warehoused in a
hospital for a while
um and it most of the time at least in
our offices experience these people are
very poor because if they had means and
had Private health insurance
they would likely be receiving the
mental health treatment that they
require in the community but because as
you all are probably painfully aware
we don't have a robust community-based
mental health system we don't even have
enough voluntary beds if someone needs a
hospitalization temporarily so people
reach the crisis Point attorneys are
appointed
now we're going to start chasing them
for fees that's what this does
the current law provides the people who
have the means to pay are supposed to
pay for those fees as a practical matter
they are not pursued and I think what
the amendment the bill is amended by the
Senate does is it really recognizes the
reality that we're talking about a
population that's getting essentially
fined for having a mental illness and we
don't want it and that's not right
so
for for those reasons I would urge you
to reject the non-germain amendment and
just let the bill pass as the senate had
amended it and I'm happy to answer any
questions you might have
questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much thank
you next I'm going to call on Maggie
Pritchard
good morning thank you for having me
um my name is Maggie Pritchard I'm the
president of the Behavioral Health
Association in New Hampshire for all the
Community Mental Health Centers who
executive directors read this
legislation Amendment and said oh my God
we can't support this and I said let me
go I really want to talk to people and I
really want to explain what it's like
because I am that person who has
assessed someone and I don't know how
many of you have had the privilege of
being with someone who is very
vulnerable and very sick and their
illness has taken over for them and
perhaps they are going to go to another
place right and you feel so privileged
to be with them as a mental health
clinician who has been with someone who
is acutely ill and saying to them I'm
terribly sorry I have to take away your
civil rights because your illness has
taken over right now and you can't have
a choice the choice now is in in someone
else's hands you have to go to the
hospital I know you don't want to go to
the hospital that's why I have to fill
out this form with this physician and
take away your rights I don't think that
if somebody is physically ill mentally
ill we should be imposing charges for
legal fees on them they couldn't make a
decision to say yes I'd like to have a
lawyer or no I wouldn't like to have a
lawyer because in the state that they're
in they are so vulnerable that I and our
physician have had to take away their
rights so I implore you to think kindly
about this and think about what it does
to human beings who suffer with major
illnesses and say no this amendment
can't fly thank you question of ask
questions for this witness
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my my question Miss Pritchard so
I just have a question so you're
mentioning not charging somebody when
they're in a mental health crisis which
I can completely sympathize with I'm
wondering
your facility or your practice when
somebody's in some type of a mental
health crisis mode do you typically
provide
free care to them yes well I work at a
mental health center so we are
contracted by the state and we take all
comers regardless of ability to pay and
particularly when people are in crisis
may I follow up yes please so if
somebody is able to pay would would you
guys pursue having them pay or if when
they're in Mental Health crisis mode
they automatically just don't have to
pay regardless of ability it's always on
ability to pay so if you have private
insurance we'll bill your insurance if
you don't have insurance will reduce
your fee to nothing if that's what you
need but we don't
put extra charges on you so to speak for
having your illness we don't you know it
wasn't a choice for them
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much man
um next I'm going to call on Holly
Stevens please
good morning excuse me good morning uh
chairman members of the committee my
name is Holly Stevens I'm the director
of public policy for Nami New Hampshire
Nami New Hampshire is a Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide to support
education and advocacy and on behalf of
New Hampshire on behalf of Nami New
Hampshire I'm here today to speak in
opposition to the amendment that's being
considered and I did just want to answer
the question that was just asked for
mobile crisis services in our state from
speaking to people in the state it's my
understanding
that while they may Bill private
insurance anything that the private
insurance does not pay is paid for by
the state so there is no out-of-pocket
cost for those crisis Services they do
build the insurer because the insurer
you have a contractual arrangement with
the insurer and they have the obligation
to pay for those Services because they
are contracted services but there is no
out-of-pocket cost to the individual for
those crisis services
um you've heard um I don't want to
repeat anything you've already heard
from Miss Rosenberg or from
from uh from Maggie so but I do want to
point out that you know since this is an
involuntary commitment the person is not
seeking treatment they don't even want
these services and many times they're
not even aware as you've heard of the
circumstances surrounding their illness
to be held against their will and then
hit with legal fees once they're stable
and released from the hospital
regardless of their ability to pay does
not seem appropriate
um
during you know when they're being seen
it's not a time to hand somebody a
financial affidavit and say can you
please fill this out and that's what the
court would need to do and prior to
getting into policy I did debt
collection for five years
I remember sitting down face to face
because the court depended on the
plaintiff's attorneys to work with the
defendants on payment arrangements for
small claims cases that was the majority
of what I did I had to help people fill
out those financial affidavits
they were not in a mental health crisis
and still could not fill them out so
you know the court would not have the
information in order to be able to make
a determination on the ability to pay
and they also wouldn't have the
documents signed under
um the Pains of penalties of perjury
which is also necessary for the court to
make a determination so I would you know
just say that it's nearly impossible for
the courts to even try to make this
determination when the person is in
front of them for the very short time
that they're that they are in front of
them and I know that judge king is here
today and I'm sure he'd be happy to let
you folks know what the process looks
like on his end if you'd like to hear
from him
currently the court is paying a hundred
dollars for that initial three-day
um probable cause hearing and sixty five
dollars for the second one
it's going to cost the office of Cost
Containment a heck of a lot more than
165 dollars to collect 165 dollars and
I'm not sure that that's a good use of
the state's money
um you know you've heard that the mental
health system as we have it today
there's been a lot of work done in the
10-year mental health plan so
I want to thank you for all the work
that's been done on that but a lot more
work needs to be done in order for folks
to have services so that money could be
spent and investing in services that if
people had those services on the front
end there's a good chance they wouldn't
end up in the emergency room in the
first place
so in addition to the information being
difficult to obtain fairness is a factor
in these situations the only thing that
people on an iea the involuntary
emergency admission are guilty of is
having a mental illness you've heard
that so we're essentially charging
people
because they're sick because they have
symptoms that are beyond their control
this is the only illness
that the state has determined if your
symptoms
are really bad
that you will you can potentially you
lose your Liberty it's the only one
um
cancer patients people with diabetes
they can all refuse treatment for
medical services and that's okay even if
it's going to kill them
you can't do that with mental health so
these folks are basically being charged
because they have a mental illness
and as you've heard waving council is
nearly impossible for these folks so
they don't even have a choice about
whether they have counsel or not and
then they're forced to pay for it
um the other
I also provided you this is testimony
that one of our members
provided to Senate finance and I just
wanted to give you guys a flavor of what
it's like to have somebody a loved one
in an emergency room I will not read it
to you you have it in front of you so
that you can read it yourself but I do
encourage you to read through the first
couple paragraphs of that before you
make any decisions on this amendment
today because it's it's painful it's
traumatic for the person going through
it it's traumatic for the family and
then to be sent Financial affidavits and
and bills for legal fees on top of it
can can also be traumatic for these
folks
so with that I will just end and I will
take any questions that the committee
has questions for this witness yes
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair I appreciate it as a visitor you
allowing me to ask a question but I just
want to make sure I'm I'm properly
oriented on what our issue is here uh
you miss Stevens you've you've said that
this is the only thing for which an
individual may be charged that they then
become and then they become responsible
for the legal bill
I think aren't we talking about an
involuntary commitment because the
person is perceived to be a danger to
themselves or to others so this so that
the use of the word charge is that
really appropriate in this circumstance
when this is a medical intervention
that's intended to protect the
individual safety or the public safety
when I said charge I don't mean charges
in a crime has been charged I mean as in
money is being charged thank you for the
clarification
other questions for this witness yes
sorry
representative germanna I'm sorry no
thank you Mr chair and I appreciate I'm
also subbing today so I appreciate the
opportunity to ask a question and and
you alluded to this at the end of your
testimony you know is it safe to say
that an individual who is experiencing a
mental health crisis and then and
receives these services
if they are then you know billed
afterwards in their attempts to follow
up and they don't have the means to pay
isn't it safe to say that this is adding
additional stressors which actually
undermines their ability to recover uh
adequately so we're we're making it
worse for that individual uh and and
their ability to to recover by pursuing
them for money that they can't pay it
absolutely is and just to give an
example
um there's a a family member of One of
Nami New Hampshire's members who went
under stress they light themselves on
fire
and their family has said if they were
to receive a bill and or a financial
affidavit it would be very very
difficult for them to deal with that and
they could end up trying to light
themselves on fire and end up back in
the ER on another involuntary admission
and then the cycle just starts all over
again so yes this can be extremely
stressful for them more stressful than
you or I who you know have a job and pay
bills every single day
thank you thank you Mr chair yes
representative Macbeth thank you I
apologize for being late and thank you
for
um taking my question and I'm not sure
if you're the right person but what is
the threshold for the um indigency what
I mean what are we looking at are we
looking at
um their income and does that include
public benefits what if they have a
house but no income or if they've saved
for renting I mean how does how do we
determine
um who's Indigent how do the judge
determine that that I don't know I think
that would be a best answered by
somebody from the court than by me I'm
not sure what they look at when they're
looking at and didn't see whether they
look at assets or not
thank you other questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you so much uh I think I don't have any
other pink cars is there anyone else who
wishes to testify
all right see yes representative Smith
um thank you Mr chair is there anyone
here from the Department of
administrative services or the Cost
Containment
um
office
is there anyone here from the judicial
Council
if that would be up to the chair no if
you have questions of course yes please
come on up
foreign
my name is Richard Sam Peril I'm the
acting executive director of the New
Hampshire judicial Council
thank you
um I
I know from the days when I served in
the judicial Council because I was chair
of this committee about the constant
Financial pressures
that that you are under in there and
fortunately our system makes it possible
for the judicial Council to go to the
fiscal committee to ask for additional
money
so in that context
are there financial implications about
this amendment that would affect the
work of the judicial Council so at the
last hearing thank you for the question
representative the last hearing on this
bill I
testified about the
the substantive part of the bill and the
financial implications for the judicial
Council there in terms of the amendment
that's proposed I'll confess I'm a
little confused about the mechanics of
how it would be done in terms of
assessing uh when a person is eligible
to pay and then
um the follow-up on that and certainly
that would be the office of Cost
Containment that would be responsible
for that collection I guess I
um do think in terms of financial
implications for the judicial Council
that the collection process itself may
involve further hearings where maybe
Council was appointed and it it seems
like maybe there may be a situation
where we're now paying Council to
collect money for Council but the
overall uh concerns here are with
respect to the
um
payment for these Services out of the
judicial council's budget without that
appropriation having been included in
the the bill in total and uh the
specific amendment in terms of the
collection determination I just don't
uh understand necessarily how that may
affect judicial council's uh payments
because I'm not clear when that process
would take place it clearly wouldn't be
at the time of the finding that a person
would be involuntarily admitted if if
they were in fact admitted that means
they're not at a position to make that
Financial commitment or determination of
responsibility so I'm not entirely clear
on how the process would play out thank
you could I follow up yes
um thank you
um
can you describe for us your the
judicial council's relationship to the
office of Cost Containment
um sure so the office of Cost
Containment is part of the Department of
administrative Services which is a
different state agency it is not part of
the judicial Council the office of Cost
Containment is responsible for the
collection of monies
those monies don't necessarily get
transferred to the judicial Council so
while the office of Cost Containment is
collecting that doesn't necessarily
translate to uh revenue for my agency
and I certainly don't oversee the folks
who work in that office so I don't have
any direct supervision authority over
those people that could if I could just
ask one more and you might not know the
answer to this
um do you have
um are you familiar with any reports
from the office of Cost Containment as
to how much
they have been able to collect
each year and the cost to the state
for their efforts to collect
um
so I have been in this position uh since
December I am aware that
in the context of indigent criminal
cases that the that there have been some
uh I think reports on the topic you're
asking about I don't off the top of my
head know what the response is or what
those reports stayed but I I can just
tell you anecdotally and generally that
I think the efforts at collection have
been
um less than successful historically
thank you thank you very much
um it just as an aside to the chair
um
you know in-service training is always
helpful for all of us and at some point
you might want to ask
um someone from the office of Costco I
mean or the commissioner to come and
explain how that all works because it's
important based on the issues that have
been raised by the committee well I
would say I did have a I actually did
have a discussion with commissioner
Ireland house about this
um and I will talk about that when we
get to the our executive session uh
representative Beth you have a question
I do thank you
um thank you for taking my question I'm
looking at the original bills that came
over to the Senate and the financial
note on it
um and when you mention the cost the
transfer of cost of responsibility of
collecting these bills is that the one
million five hundred thousand dollars at
your time so it's an unfunded mandate if
you will that you'll be collecting so
thank you for that question
um the cost is
um unclear in the sense that uh my
calculations that are in the fiscal note
on the bill are based upon the court
rules that allocate the the fees in
these types of cases in addition to my
calculations there are there was some
information provided by Health and Human
Services about what they used to pay in
these kinds of cases when they were
responsible
and then there was also testimony by uh
Attorney Richard head who was at the
judicial branch at that time and
um indicating the cost that they are the
the courts are currently paying in these
types of cases uh which is a flat
hundred dollar fee in the main hearing
and then as was testified about I think
there's a follow-up fee of 65 so so in
terms of the budgeting for my agency If
This Were to be enacted my calculations
are based upon the the cost under the
rule but my expectation is that uh at
least based upon what the current
contract is with the judicial branch
that it's about a hundred dollars a
hearing for for these types of types of
hearings and I I think probably uh judge
king is probably better equipped to
answer the actual cost per hearing but
and I'm sorry this is a circuitous way
of answering your question which was yes
that's what we calculate the cost may be
for this
somebody follow up yes thank you so
um the bill says it goes into effect if
it passes in 60 days so how will your
agency of the county how does it take
people off to do what's going to be the
impact of of the passage of this yes so
thank you for that question at the last
hearing uh representative Smith
um asked me some other questions about
that
um I think 60 days is a
um
you know a very tight time frame I don't
I'm not sure where that money
specifically comes from other than it's
out of the Indigent defense fund there's
no specific line for this currently
there are other Guardian type situations
where we do pay so ultimately
I can understand how it may be
appropriate to transfer this payment
responsibility to the judicial Council
um would I like that to occur maybe at
the beginning of the next biennium so
that we could include that in our budget
request and including maybe additional
staff because we get these increased
responsibilities to make payments
absolutely that would be far preferred
for me uh in this situation
um Mr chair if I could just I'm
realizing just as full disclosure I do
not accept these type of cases but I do
work for the do do some cases in which
I'm paid for out of an injured Fund in
the Probate Court
thank you so just if I could follow up
with uh Mr sample
with regard to the last point and last
question that was raised by
representative Macbeth mcbeath Macbeth
um that
the transfer of funds from uh to uh I'm
sorry the transfer for responsibility
for the payment where it comes from
whether there's a reimbursement or not
um that would exist that I mean if even
if we pass the original bill there would
be that transfer of funding is that
correct absolutely okay so and you know
what the last thing the other thing I
wanted to ask you is
um
the purpose of having the here the the
whole purpose of having this hearing was
really based on section two of the bill
and I'm just wondering
um do you have any
do you have any sense as to
um whether in the sort of in the overall
scheme of things it makes sense to have
a statute like section two
I appreciate that question
um and I'm going to answer
um both as sort of the my current
position as as an agency had for for
this agency but also uh
should share with you my background
which I know the chair knows uh as a
practicing lawyer who represented uh
clients in Indigent criminal cases where
the office of Cost Containment was often
asked to collect fees
um I
I have a hard time
understanding the practical value on
imposing an OCC collection requirement
from persons who are involuntarily
admitted the people who actually maybe
don't get admitted and are found to be
not a danger
seem to be those are the persons that
you would be in the position of actually
collecting from because they're
competent they can engage in a
conversation and yet they're now
involved in a court proceeding they
never asked to be involved in and now
we're being asked to be paid for it so
it it doesn't seem to be from my
personal perspective a
effective means of collecting any real
relevant money substantial money for
purposes of what uh
is being expended here all right thank
you other questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much
all right again uh let me ask you anyone
who wishes to uh speak anyone further
who wishes to speak
seeing none all right thank you
I'm going to close a hearing on the
amendment to SB 128
and I guess we're ready for executive
session I think we've got everybody here
now yes
um
so since it's my Amendment
um I guess I would uh
I would
um
speak first
I think it's important to understand
that
the original SB 28 as it came to us from
the Senate does two things
first the transfers payment
responsibility
um from as I understand it right now uh
being paid
uh by the Department of Health and Human
Services
uh to the judicial Council
and secondly it removes the requirement
and I think this is very important to
stress here it removes the requirement
that exists under present law
that non-indigent persons repay pay or
repay for Council Services That's the
Law right now that that uh if you are
able to pay for and if you're provided
an attorney and you're able to repay the
law right now is that you are supposed
to repay
um
so I think my my uh proposed amendment
um I think that point number one
transferring responsibility to the
judicial Council that makes perfect
sense to me
um I I think that's a very good idea
um
point two however is where I strongly
disagree
um and that was the basis for my
Amendment
um as I as we've discussed before
section two is uh is the non-germain
aspect and I will address that in just a
second but first let me refer to section
one
um because I think it's important
um to note several things
um this my proposed amendment one
retains the requirement of current law
that non-indigent persons uh pay for
counsel uh when they receive counsel and
I think it's very important to
understand here that although the focus
of our discussion has been on the
involuntary emergency admission the
three-day hearing that's not that's not
the only thing as the footnote as the
fiscal note in the original Bill
indicates that's not the only thing
we're talking about we're also talking
about non-emergency admissions
um the where that where this proposed
change to the council saying you don't
have to reimburse that would apply to
non-emergency admissions also where
right now the Supreme Court is is the
cause the cost of that is six hundred
dollars per per case and that's where
that that's figure is where uh the the
fiscal note came up comes up with the
idea of almost of I think it's a million
nine
um as the I'm sorry a million uh a
million five is the cost overall of uh
of this of of this service and it's also
important to emphasize that that does
not include the cost of ancillary
services like if uh and I suspect this
would probably be more likely to occur
in the uh in the non-emergency context
where there's a longer proposed uh
commitment or that may be a longer
commitment but uh investigative and
ancillary services like a private
investigator or experts or that kind of
thing would also be be paid
um by uh would be paid out of the
judicial Council and under the original
bill would not be subject to
reimbursement even if the person could
pay
um so I um I think that's I think that's
very important to understand
um I am completely sympathetic
to the idea that people many probably
most of the people that are facing
involuntary uh commitment whether it's
on an emergency basis and that maybe is
even even more uh uh uh problematic but
even those not a non-emergency it's
still an involuntary commitment that
those people are often in very difficult
circumstances and so I tried to word
this uh proposed amendment and I should
say in consultation with I spoke with
just uh with judge king about this and I
don't mean I don't want to misinterpret
his position I think he would prefer uh
the original amendment to my proposed
amendment also but I did speak with him
in an effort to try to alleviate some of
the concerns that were raised so that
for example the way the amendment is
worded it says that
um the person has a responsibility to
pay for counsel and then it goes on to
say that
um if the person is unable to to pay the
court shall appoint an attorney who will
be compensated at the rate determined by
the Supreme Court that's the that's the
current law it then goes on to say that
if the court is unable to make the
determination and for example the you
know we've heard the circumstances of
somebody's really in trauma uh the last
thing you want to do is ask them to fill
out a financial affidavit right now fine
the court can say I'm this this this
establishes the default position that
the court appoints counsel for the
person and then refers the matter to the
office of Cost Containment and they will
then make a report and recommendation
back to the court
it should also be noted here that the
office of Cost Containment has the ha
they have the discretion to make a
recommendation to the court that we
we're not going to be able to collect
any money from this person we should
just waive recollection efforts and my
understanding from having spoken to rep
to Charlie arlinghaus from the
Department of administrative Services is
that they do that with some frequency
they say when you know this is as as was
pointed out this is going to cost us too
much to try to recollect to try to
collect so let's not let's not try to
collect
um so I'm
I I've tried to make this as
user-friendly if you will as it can be
so that the so that the the court and I
and I also think that you know we we
have to have some confidence in our
judges I I have great confidence in the
fact that judges will be able to make
appropriate determinations for example
there may be I think I I as again I
referred to a discussion I had with
judge king it may very well be that that
when a judge is first facing a first
confronted with this situation the
circumstances themselves even if there's
no financial affidavit the circumstances
themselves may may be such that the
judge can make a finding this person is
Indigent and can't repay I mean as an
example suppose suppose you had a police
officer that brings uh that brings
somebody in and there's evidence that
the person has been has been homeless
for the last 60 days and has been
begging for food or something like that
at various places it seems to me that
the judge very well may say I'm based
upon the evidence that I've heard I'm
going to find this person who's Indigent
and doesn't have to repay
um now that may you know obviously there
are a million different circumstances
that might cause the judge to exercise
his discretion uh one way or the other
or to say well I'm going to appoint
counsel now because I don't really I
don't know but uh but I have enough
questions that I want the office of Cost
Containment uh to look into this
um uh but I don't see any I don't see
any any problem with that the other
thing that I guess I that I think is
kind of important if we're talking about
fairness here is this
if somebody suppose that we have
somebody that's you know that's sort of
you know in the middle class or upper
middle class or even even wealthy I
presume that sometimes those people can
be in be an emergency crisis situation
and have uh and be petitioned to be
involuntarily admitted and if that
person shows up with a lawyer
of his of of their own of their own
choosing and they pay for that lawyer
presumably at a lot more than six
hundred dollars
um
do they get to bill the state to get
their money back can they say you know I
gee I hired you know ropes and gray or I
hired uh uh Divine millimet or some some
Law Firm that charged me five thousand
or ten thousand dollars for a hearing uh
I want the money back because I I didn't
ask for this hearing we would under our
current law we would say no I'm sorry
that you don't get your money back
that's that's just one of the things
that you know that's one of the things
that that happens and so if that's true
why should somebody and bear in mind I'm
talking about somebody who has the
ability to repay not somebody who
doesn't but if it's true that if you get
your own lawyer and you pay for your own
lawyer you don't you don't get to get
that money back from the state then why
should somebody who is able to repay
even though they may be at a lower in a
sort of lower economic status why do
they not have to repay and again it's
not we're not talking about the office
of Cost Containment you know becoming
you know sort of everybody's uh
uh view of you know the villainous bill
collector who's calling in the middle of
the night or using aggressive uh efforts
to re to to collect money uh that
nothing like that is is that nothing
could be further from the truth
but why should they not have to why
should they not have to repay in
circumstances where they're able to
repay and the last point I would make on
this is
you know I think we're we're
the suggestion has been from the
witnesses that
well these people uh are you know
they're they're all never going to be
able to repay and they're all going to
be traumatized and they're all going to
sort of fight
if they have to repay but is that really
true may I don't doubt that that may be
true in many cases but isn't this sort
of the you know the in some sense the
kind of discrimination of low
expectations that
um that because this may apply to to
many people uh we should assume it
applies to all of them why isn't it why
shouldn't we assume that there will be
some people who are have who may have
had an emergency uh mental mental crisis
but they get over it and when they get
over it when somebody sends them when
the office of Cost Containment says hey
we think you can reimburse the state for
whatever it is a hundred dollars or 600
they're going to say they're going to
send a check why should we assume that
that wouldn't be the case in in all
cases
but of course if we say that you don't
have to send a check then they won't I
would I certainly wouldn't do it if I
hadn't didn't have any obligation to do
it but I submit respectfully that the
law shouldn't be that you shouldn't have
to do that if you can't
and that's it I'll shut up and listen to
anybody else who has a view
representative Turner
can I just ask a couple of questions
about what uh the statement um because
I'm just going back to the original
Senate uh referred Bill and and looking
at the language
one of the thoughts and maybe I misheard
it at the beginning did you say somehow
this opens the door
to charges for people who are not being
involuntarily committed was that one no
no no I said it it it applies to people
in being involuntarily committed either
on an emergency basis or a non-emergency
basis
and then then just the second point that
I want to clarify but when you were
saying before about people asking to be
reimbursed if they come in with a lawyer
it seems in the Senate bill that it sort
of clearly states that it um sought to
be admitted and does not have legal
counsel so I don't know if that clears
up that part of of what you were saying
or if you were making a different point
because it seems to the way I'm reading
this it seems to suggest that that if
they do have legal counsel then then
this wouldn't apply to them no no no no
by the point that I was really making is
that if you under if we if we adopted
the original bill
what that would say is if you are a
petitioned to be involuntarily admitted
either on an emergency basis or a
non-emergency basis and you show up with
your privately retained lawyer yes the
court will not appoint counsel for you
but my point would be if you show up
with your own lawyer and you pay your
lawyer you don't get to you don't get to
charge the state you don't get to say oh
listen I just got this bill from Divine
millimet for five thousand dollars uh
State I want you to reimburse me that
that was my point
okay yeah it does I don't see how I read
that in here but but because it does
sort of say this pertains to people who
do not have legal counsel but
yeah no no I guess my I guess what I'm
saying is you're right it's not in there
so that since there's no since there's
no provision in the law that says if you
if you pay your own lawyer you get to to
suit to uh charge the state for it you
don't get to do that because it's not in
the law
representative Macbeth thank you thank
you for taking my question I just want
to clarify your testimony here today
you're saying that um as you understand
it this bill judges currently without
have the discretion to declare someone
Indigent without the filing of a
financial affidavit yes I think they do
I think they do and that's going to
expand to the 604 as well
to that RSA 604
um you mean it's actually the section
the section also that you're I mean I I
suppose theoretically although you know
I I I agree that it would be if somebody
if you were talking about it because 604
Maya section 2 is not limited to
um uh involuntary admissions it could
apply in other circumstances and so I
guess I would I would I would agree that
in other circumstances if you're not
talking about somebody that is more
likely to be incompetent
um then maybe it is less likely that the
court could do that without a financial
affidavit but I suppose there could be
circumstances which the court could
and also
um then that this if this change would
be inconsistent with the court rules
that require State appointed attorneys
to file the approved financial affidavit
so they wouldn't could put a chilling
effect on their ability to be paid
terribly
I'm sorry
no no this doesn't have anything to do
when a court appointed attorney files
their bill with the court to be paid
they need to file the the copy of the
financial affidavit that's approved with
the court order saying that
um the person is indigent
right plus their itemized Bill and their
order of appointments so
well if the court if the court has made
a finding and has issued an order that
the person is Indigent
um I would I would be very surprised if
that wasn't if you would if you didn't
if you attached that to your bill I
would be very surprised if you wouldn't
get paid I wouldn't be surprised
generally the the judicial council is
very
um
pays attention to everything that's in
the rules
are there yes uh representative
Stapleton
thank you Mr chair um
I appreciate the question and the answer
of the question of Representative
relative to
other cases
because before I heard that
I was taking a broad view other cases
where well I know it says other sections
of this chapter
but for those of us who are not
practicing attorneys and not familiar
with how the
segment these sort of things
my mind thought that it could be applied
to any other tort or even criminal cases
so I think other cases it would have
been helpful to have that Modified by
the voluntary or involuntary admission
so for that reason I'm having
some problems with
kind of the unclear and open nature of
other cases in the section too
and
otherwise if that were clear I feel that
section 2 would support an edify section
one section one makes it a given
that the person is responsible for the
charges unless indigency can be
determined and
in if the need is there then the court
appoints an attorney for that
determination
so I'm perfectly comfortable with
And subscribe to section one
but section two leaves me a little
queasy without the clarification of that
voluntary and involuntary aspect of
admissions sure no no that's that's was
the emergency I should say either
emergency or non-emergency of the
involuntary admission sure no no you
know that was the point that
representative Smith made and and I I
have to say given given the comments of
both of you
um
you know I I take those I I give very
serious weight to this I I guess what I
would what I would say is
uh as a point of clarification but this
may you know this sort of suggests that
we representative Smith's proposed
amendment is the better way to go but
what I what I was saying is in answered
your question I actually was section two
I was not specifically thinking of
emergency of uh involuntary admissions I
was I had drafted section two as kind of
a catch-all because for the reasons I
said before this sort of issue has come
up enough where the court of appoints an
attorney for some reason in some you
know some case that had not been sort of
thought about before and then the court
is concerned that that's going to come
out of the Court's budget where they the
court really believes it should come out
of the judicial Council budget and so
that's why I drafted section two it
really had nothing to do with with uh
involuntary admissions as such it was
just that
the the fact that that issue came on you
know here was yet another circumstance
involving involuntary admissions where
the question came up of who should pay
and I just thought I'd draft section two
as a let's just have a catch-all
provision so that if some if some other
thing arises in the future we know where
the payment comes from but
I I appreciate your your concern because
candidly I'd have to say I don't as we
as I sit here right now I don't know
what those other circumstances might be
and it I have to I would have to concede
that it might make sense to have a
hearing you know to introduce that part
of the bill next year and have a hearing
and people can testify and see if there
really are any other circumstances so I
mean that I'm I think you raise a very
good point representative Smith
thank you if I could just follow up on
this recent exchange I'm a little
confused because you've mentioned
um the involuntary admissions several
times in your comments but as I
understand it that is a civil
procedure whereas very specifically
section 2 deals with proceedings in
criminal cases and involuntary admission
is not a criminal case
I say that as a non-lawyer and certainly
is a non-judge so you can feel free to
correct well you know no you know you
know what you that's you're right in
this in this sense it does expand it
to to these kinds of proceedings but
section 604a even though it is in the
criminal law section already does have
does apply to juvenile cases which are
not criminal cases either those are
though now there's there's an analogy
obviously between a juvenile delinquency
case and a criminal case but those are
specifically defined in the law 169b as
not being criminal cases so
I understand your point but I think that
it probably is not a bad idea to to
house
if you were going to have section two it
would probably not be a bad idea to
house it in 604a
thank you and and I'm I'm not
comfortable with what I'm about to ask
but
I know but I'm still going to ask it I
believe firmly in the separation of
powers
and we have three separate branches
and the last thing I would want to do
is put any member
of the judicial branch in an
uncomfortable position
but I wonder if there
are any
clarifications
that the judicial branch
could share with us based on the
discussions that have been taking place
up until now
so indirectly I'm asking you what you
think about
that
all right all right
in other words are you asking if judge
yeah everybody I'm looking at you
Justice game I would I guess what I
would I would like judge king to feel
absolutely free to say that he has
nothing to add and I would completely
respect that
but if he were to think that he could
um clarify any perhaps vagueness or
misconceptions that we have then and if
you were willing to share that I would
like to hear it how's that is that a
better way to put it that's fine but he
is free to say he has nothing else to
say
I looked around it looks like I'm the
only one here for the judicial branch so
my name is David King I'm the
administrative judge of the Circuit
Court I think microphone judge it's red
is it good yeah you're on it's on you
just have to speak into it I think
I've learned this morning that the
non-germaine amendment is the second
part which I did speak about with the
chair and I think what we were
contemplating is there any case criminal
or civil juvenile abuse neglect
guardianship
where under 490 31 the judicial branch
is on the hook for the fees if there's
not a specific statute and I think at
one point the example was appointing
counsel for a parent in an abuse neglect
case after the Supreme Court found that
that was not a constitutional right and
there was a point where we couldn't
appoint counsel for parents unless we
the judicial branch paid so I think
that's sort of the scenario that you're
thinking of and I think
um 604 and Mr sample can correct me if
I'm wrong but 604
um it says proceedings in criminal cases
adequate representation for Indigent
defendants in criminal cases and then it
says appointment and payment for Council
and ancillary services in other cases so
I think it's not limited to just
criminal cases
so in in 604 as it the way it's worded
right now correct right I think for
example appointment of Council in an
abuse neglect case which is clearly not
a criminal case is paid out of 604a so I
think it's not it's even though criminal
is mentioned I think it's wider than
that and so and then there's some
not confusion maybe but you've taught
you've just for point of clarification
an iea is the involuntary emergency
admission those are the ones that
are on a very short timeline I did those
hearings Monday morning
uh the docking and Concord Monday
morning
on the 11 o'clock list there were two
cases one was filed at 9 34 that morning
one was filed at 9 45 so the files were
opened in the clerk's office at 9 30 in
the morning I had a hearing at 11 and my
guess is the orders went out around 11
30. so those cases were actually opened
in our court for maybe two and a half
hours in their clothes and we're done
with them so
any finding of energy is going to have
to occur after the fact we have to
appoint counsel and lucky we can find a
lawyer on 15 minutes notice to get a
hold of the client and prepare and and
do the hearing so we've talked about
that Mr chairman about how we would
implement this and obviously we would
try our best at a hearing and those two
cases one was a 15 year old girl that's
pretty easy and the second was a 22 year
old who had been released from the state
hospital three hours before being picked
up to be re-i8 I think the Judge would
be able to check boxes on those easily
but we we don't have the ability to get
a financial affidavit obviously on the
front end of an iea case that's opened
at the very most for three days
but you know can I just ask you my
understanding is as I look at the
statute I understand that the the the
you know the the emergency admission is
presents the the particular issues
you're you're talking about but the the
right if we were to pass the original
Bill well uh under either the original
bill or my Amendment or representative
Smith's Amendment the the council right
applies not only to emergency admission
but even to the longer term I mean if
you still have the right to counsel and
appointed counsel if you're Indigent
even in the longer term admission
correct and so the fee for the iea is
negotiated by contract with the judicial
branch and the four lawyers who take
those cases they were getting paid 62 a
case
by Department of Health and Human
Services even though the statute
actually required I think a fair reading
was the court to appoint in Pay we never
have done that and because we changed
the process and and sped it up and we
now most of the hearings we conduct the
petitionee or the patient is actually in
an acute care hospital one of the 26
acute care hospitals around the state
it's a lot more work for the lawyers so
we negotiated the hundred dollar fee the
65 fee that's been mentioned I believe
that applies to when someone is on a
conditional discharge from the hospital
and that's revoked they're entitled to
an administrative hearing it doesn't
involve the courts I think DHHS pays 65
for that so that's that's apples and
oranges to this the involuntary
commitments what I call the probate
commitments that's about 600 cases a
year this the Supreme Court has a cap of
six hundred dollars but those cases are
on a 15-day cycle and they the fees
rarely get close to 600 because they're
done pretty quickly but I think you're
right Mr chairman this statute applies
to both categories they're both under
135c
questions for this Witness
thank you I'm sorry no question so thank
I'm sorry did you have a question yeah I
guess just following up on on the
thought of the voluntary versus or the
emergency versus
non-emergency and sorry if I'm
struggling with this because I'm just
not familiar but uh the the original
statute covers both in your opinion
emergent and non-emergent
um with the non-emergent
involuntary admissions still basically
require representation
yes
and those fees are currently still paid
by DHHS we don't we don't we don't um
pay those Judiciary Council
and I don't know that there's any
immediate
discussion about changing that but for
that's the way it's always been done the
council submit their fees to the court
and we pass them through to DHHS they
also pay the fees for the independent
psychiatrists which are much higher
um
in addition to the council fees
currently
but I I mean I guess you know I guess
I understand what you're saying but I
guess if you read either the original
Senate bill
or either representative Smith or my
Amendment
that seems to say that whatever the
practice has been the the those funds
should come out of the judicial Council
that's the way the bill is worded right
now
right the statute that's being amended
is in the section of 135c that deals
with ieas but I think a fair reading is
it says under this chapter which is 135c
exactly exactly yes representative
Macbeth thank you Mr would you allow me
to ask my question I had asked before
that someone said judge king would be
best to answer about what is what is the
threshold of indigency
benefits concluded in income how how
Indigent do you have to be to
qualify anyone that is on only exempt
income Social Security those kinds of
income is automatically under our rules
entitled to appointed counsel
um we we have not developed
um guidelines for this particular case
type yet
but I can tell you that I've been doing
these for a while I don't think many
people are going to be able to pay
Council fees they're in a mental state
such that they're danger to themselves
or others by the nature of the case so I
think the biggest concern that we will
have in implementing this is just how to
parse that out and it's going to be I
think OCC that's going to have to figure
that out not the court the way this bill
is worded
I think that was the intention that
you're absolutely right that was the
intent to have and as I said I did speak
to commissioner arlinghaus about this
and you know that's I mean that's what
they do
uh representative cuta
So currently is the determination
for if somebody can pay or not generally
made by the court or how is it generally
made right now if if you're gonna seek
reimbursement of the fees I just want to
understand if this is changing the
current process as it is today or if
it's relatively similar if you could
please explain I'd appreciate it sure So
currently for the what I'll call the
mental health case is the 135c both the
ieas and the probate commitments those
fees have been paid for many years by
DHHS I don't know if there's any process
to seek reimbursement but generally in
the court system if it's a criminal case
before we appoint Council we require a
financial affidavit the the major
difference being those cases go on for
for months and so there's plenty of time
on the front end of the case to make
that determination
um same in the abuse neglect cases the
any anytime we appoint counsel we get a
financial affidavit and determine an
agency guardianships of incapacitated
adults on the 464a there's a financial
affidavit that's completed and if
they're eligible under our guidelines we
appoint counsel we have Point counsel
anyway uh but if they are not eligible
then there's a reimbursement on the back
end of the case but the difference I
think and I think the important
distinction is that these cases move so
quickly that we certainly in the ieas
don't have the ability on the front end
of the case to determine indigency which
is why I think the bill was drafted in
such a way that that would be up to OCC
we would do what we could add a hearing
to see if the judge could make that
quick determination which in in many
cases I think will be the case but in
the case where it's not clear
somebody's going to have to track the
person down we may not have a good
address and maybe someone who is
presently homeless or the petitioner is
a a friend or just getting the petition
filed but doesn't have complete
information about the petition e who's
stuck in a hospital somewhere and so
there may be OCC may have some trouble
tracking the person down on the back end
of the case but again we would do
everything that we could at the time of
the hearing whether it was two hours
after it was filed or or two days to to
see if we could make if the judge could
make that determination at a hearing and
hopefully check a box uh if it's if
there's going to be a finding of no
intimacy and that and close the file
yes follow-up
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my follow-up question
um if that determination was made and
you would check that box I wanted to
kind of follow up on Macbeth's question
would that be accepted by the court as
you know the documentation that the
person couldn't pay if the judge had
checked off this box to ensure that this
attorney would in fact be reimbursed
their their fee and we wouldn't be
making them
fill out even more paperwork to try and
determine if the judge had already
determined
they'll be paid by the judicial Council
the question is whether OCC will recoup
that hundred dollars sometime down the
road so the lawyers are going to get
paid
I if I answered your question
representative
and it won't be as we won't re require
the notice of appointment the financial
affidavit and the itemized bill because
it's a flat fee and the lawyers get paid
that fee the hearings done they've done
their work and and the case is closed
any other questions saying none thank
you very much thank you
could I just quickly ask clarification
you've referred several times to the
original Bill do you mean the original
bill or do you mean the bill as amended
by the Senate as it came to us I'm sorry
I I meant the bill as amended by the
Senate thank you
um
so um I I guess I want to go around as
to whether there's any further
discussion but I I guess what I what I'd
really like to say is I
I think and maybe I'm being overly
optimistic I I think
that there may not be
a lot of difference between the
positions around the table in in this
sense I'm I've tried to draft this bill
in a way that gives the cler the court
and the office of Cost Containment
maximum flexibility to deal with the
kinds of situations that they are likely
to deal with in many cases involving
involuntary admissions whether it's on
an emergency basis or not
while still retaining the principle
that if a person can repay
they should repay and I think that's I
guess I would say I think that's an
important principle
um and I think it reflects a principle
of fairness because if somebody does get
their own lawyer and pays their own
lawyer they don't get to have that
reimbursed by the state
so why should somebody who by definition
is able to repay
but gets a free attorney at the outset
not have to repay and again it's not to
you know that the the OCC is going to
become this you know terrible collection
agency that's uh calling people in the
middle of the night and doing all those
things that's not the way OCC has ever
operated but why shouldn't they be able
to make the the
do what they need to do to uh to uh
seek reimbursement from somebody who's
gotten a free service and as I said
before
why do we why do why is it appropriate
to think that
no one that everybody who is is uh is
asked to reimburse will be
um will not be will not say uh you know
here yes I owe the money and here's the
and here's the uh here's the check why
is it a pro why should we be thinking
that nobody will do that and that's
really all this bill says is that if you
can pay you should pay so that that's
why I favor the bill you know my that's
why I favor representative Smith cement
yes
um representative Turner
yeah I just wanted to lift up I guess
one of the statements from and I'm
struggling to figure out which of our of
our Witnesses in the hearing said it
um
that with involuntary admission I think
for me the distinction is that the
person's not seeking
um any services in other words this is
not something that someone came and said
I wish to be defended against you know
the the charges against me or anything
like that that this is this is basically
something that the state is doing to
this person over there essentially
either objection or or inability to to
object
um and I think to me that's maybe the
distinction between why we would or
would not seek reimbursement for
um the services is really because the
person's not asking for the service it's
really the state that's asking for the
service and the way I'm thinking about
it sure but so can I just but I mean
then then should we uh should we have
another amendment to the bill that says
if you if you are one of the few people
that's Bill Gates and you pay your own
attorney then you can re you can bill
the state
I mean why wouldn't that be fair then
too because you haven't in in that
circumstance you haven't asked for that
proceeding either
right I guess what I'm saying is Bill
Gates would not if he's being
involuntarily admitted would not be
asking you know for someone to represent
him the court essentially is saying in
order to to make this a fair process
they need somebody appointed so that so
that they're not you know essentially
incapacitated and unable to
um
you know unable to accept or not accept
you know the help of the court so
other comments
uh if yes representative Stapleton
I think section one makes it clear
um and it enables people with means
to be billed for
the legal
Services engaged in the process
um
but you know dealing with these folks
that need
that need an involuntary admission
emergency or non-emergency
they happen to be involved as a POA in a
case with an Indigent homeless person
right now
and it is one horrendous
huge gigantic chore
eliciting information
I've got about two volumes four inches
thick of the person's history
person is like relates to the Johnny
Cash song I've Been Everywhere Man
and he has been and I have been able to
determine his financial subsistence and
his condition
um and he's only on SSI has no assets
has no other income no pensions
um and he dissipates that because of his
mental condition and to um
an email romance fraud scam
and we have to keep him away from his
money in order not to dissipate those
funds that he needs for his living and
expenses and
medical and so forth um
he doesn't even want to pay his own debt
obligations which amount to about twenty
thousand dollars now so as his POA
that's what I'm doing is trying to
manage him away from his money and
trying to clear up some of his debts
because the principle we live by if you
pay your debts otherwise it's tough to
service us if you take something and
don't want to pay for it and willfully
don't want to pay for it
but this person is on the verge of being
in a court petition for
uh involuntary admission
so we're trying to kind of help him
along and give them some instruction as
to why we need to he needs to pay his
debts while paying his debts and
eliminate more Court actions to try to
collect money from him
so I can understand
the the need to help these folks and
they they need we need to decide for
them when they're incapable of decision
um to care for themselves or to manage
their money or to be even able to live
on their own
but when somebody comes into the process
that's got a family wealth subsistence
resources
um
which is probably the smaller part of
these sort of cases I would I would
assume that they're going to pay for it
and they should pay for anything that's
uh
done for their benefit and even though
they might be unwilling
they need to be in care
and they need to be admitted and you
know that costs money and the taxpayers
got to pay for that
so if there is an ability to pay I
believe that there should be
payment and if you can't determine it
right off because the emergency nature
and the short hearing process then after
the fact as section one provides to
enable recovery from those persons who
are capable
and I think that's what section one does
once again I I like section two to
reinforce the concept of the right of
Council and legal assistance
but expanding it into
cover into criminal and tort um
I don't know it's like stretching your
arm out here to refer to an obligation
or a process I I just come to be
uncomfortable with section two I'm sorry
about that no no I hear you I think you
you and representative Smith have raised
very valid points that persuade me that
I've I I will go with her proposal
representative kutab and then
representative Horrigan
so I guess the part that has really
stuck with me is that the person is also
not asking for mental health treatment
and
if there's an ability to pay the
hospital is going to make them reimburse
for the mental health costs because
those aren't free if the person can't
pay then no they don't they won't have
to but it's going to be the same
situation where the hospital is not
going to immediately be able to
determine their financial status
and they're going to provide them the
emergency services but then after the
fact they're either going to have to
use their insurance if they have it or
if they don't have it and they have an
ability to pay they'll have to pay or if
they have no ability to pay it all then
you know maybe the hospital will set
them up with another program but I think
and I do sympathize with the fact that
it is completely stressful but in
weighing it
is a hundred dollar attorney Bill really
going to be like the the height of their
stress when they've also got potentially
uh thirty thousand dollar mental health
treatment bill you know on the same
because we have to be realistic those
mental health bills are
extremely expensive so I guess with
those points in mind and weighing it out
I think
it's similar to the way that the law
already is today
and if the judge can determine at the
time that's great just to alleviate the
person's concerns that maybe they'll be
charged later
and if the judge can't determine then
when they're able and in a better State
they could fill out the paperwork
hopefully with help
representative Horgan yes I well
underlining what
General lady just said of the uh I think
the individual regardless of whether or
not they have interior and practice
funded their proposal if they're getting
to the points where they're getting
involuntarily admission hearing Aaron
pretty severe crisis the system hasn't
worked and I'm not too troubled if they
get a what seems to be a fairly small
attorney's fee we did hear that it cost
almost as much they don't go after these
fees anyway because it would cost more
to recover them than it does to uh just
write off the fee so I'm not too worried
somebody gets even six hundred dollars
for an attorney you know I'm not can't
imagine Bill Gates be in this situation
there may be other billionaires we've
seen in the news lately could get in
that situation but um so I would say uh
I would say what the Senate has seems
like the best solution to problem I'm
not really
I don't think I'm going to lose too much
sleep over somebody getting a few
hundred dollars in free services I'm not
sure whether you're chasing these people
is a good idea
anyway and also of course
um if it's involuntarily Mission um the
person
by definition doesn't want to get to
Services they want to be back out on the
street and really
most of the time people are advocating
for people in that kind of Crisis
they're having a hard time even getting
the services so this is uh
kind of uh we're kind of looking at the
we may be looking at the uh like say the
telescope through the wrong end of the
if you may be looking at it at the wrong
end of the telescope that you know
probably the bigger problem is probably
people who need Services
um can be convinced to get to services
but who can't get them so I'm uh
you know there's probably a fairly small
number of cases where the advocate we're
like The Advocate could even be
successful in uh getting the person uh
you know not admitted to get to services
so which of course are much more
expensive than the legal fees too so
other yes representative Stapleton
yeah that
um testimony by uh representative Oregon
is helpful to put it in perspective but
under under the section one if there's
investigative expert or other services
in connection with the hearings held
under this chapter
I got to imagine that that could run
into some substantial money
um and once again with my experience a
lot of time was devoted in uncovering
the financial capabilities or that lack
thereof of of the
the person I'm a POA for so I could
appreciate well the flat fee is not a
big matter investigative reporting and
other services could be
fairly substantial
yes representative Macbeth thank you um
I have to just input here it's really is
quite a privilege for anyone to not
think that a hundred dollars a month is
a significant amount of money for some
of the people that live in our
communities I know for a fact that it is
and that's just one hundred dollars and
particularly if you've been
involuntarily committed and you're
trying to save money for a down payment
to
um you know get in an apartment have a
deposit a hundred dollars will keep you
out of that place to live and you'll
find yourself unhoused again and perhaps
in the same situation that you were so I
also know that these cord
these fees to be paid back that's going
to be a court order so that's also going
to be something that's going to be held
against you and can be brought forward
in any
um you know and if you default on it or
whatever I don't I don't know all the
procedures of that but I
um
it is significant and I um I just need
to speak up for the part of the
communities that I know that this will
could be a significant setback
financially for people that are at the
most vulnerable parts of of our towns
thank you
other comments yes representative
Edwards
I think one's a a clarification for me
and then another is just something I
haven't heard yet and uh clarification I
think is that this is about trying to uh
have those with the ability to pay to
pay and so for those people a hundred
dollars is a hundred dollars because
they have the ability to pay for it uh I
I think that's the clarification I'm
seeking we're talking about people who
have the ability to pay right that's
right and I guess I would say my my
understanding I think this they've been
doing this for years and years in
criminal cases they the office of Cost
Containment in you and to use
representative Macbeth's situation uh
example they may very well say to that
person wait all you can afford to pay is
ten dollars a month and then and then
the second thing but I just don't think
I've heard anyone mention is that these
Services aren't free somebody's paying
for them uh the New Hampshire taxpayer
we should always remember the New
Hampshire taxpayers in the room with us
when we're talking about spending money
even if they've not been invited to
provide testimony
excellent point other yes uh I'm sorry
representative germanna German I'm sorry
that's going to remember your name I
promise that's that's fine I appreciate
the opportunity to to to make uh my
points as someone who uh didn't have any
background on this bill until I was uh
you know volunteered to be a sub and
then did a little bit of reading up on
it so it could be informed but my
question coming in was whether or not
the Amendments spoke to an actual
physical impact or whether it was the
principle of the idea that people who
have the means should should pay it
seems to me if we're looking at a
million five I think that the chair
referred to earlier in terms of a
physical note the vast majority of that
it seems to be very clear we're not
going to recoup right we're talking
about a very rare number of maybe even
hypothetical cases where people do have
the means and then we would pursue
um we would pursue repayment in that
case we're talking about a small number
of people that we would be spending
money that we Pro we may not even be
able to recoup the amount of money that
we're spending trying to get that money
back and so if this is primarily about
the principle which it seems to be it
doesn't seem to be ultimately about
physical impact on the state it's about
the principle and are we going to spend
taxpayers money maybe not even break it
even pursuing based on principle a very
small number of cases so uh that that's
the question I had coming in as it said
it seems to me that ultimately both for
the well-being of the individuals
involved and considering New Hampshire
taxpayers ultimately uh it's not worth
it to pursue it simply on the grounds of
principle
other comments yeah yes representative
yeah just building on that because I I
feel like there's kind of two levels to
this
um and the the first level and maybe I'm
still misunderstanding this book but I
believe judge king when when uh he was
speaking to us said that that currently
if if the Senate bill as amended
um encompasses both emergent and
non-emergent involuntary admissions that
the more expensive non-emergent
involuntary admissions are already being
paid for by the state and it seems as
though uh I think it was DHHS if if I
got that right you know isn't seeking
reimbursement for
for that representation again because
it's involuntary you know and then the
second piece I think Falls to what I
think representative tremonta just spoke
to which is on the other instance the
amount of money that is at stake is
generally going to be so low that that
the
um
that that the the the process of even
determining whether or not to refer it
for collections
um might exceed or or or consume almost
all of the value
um so I think with those two ideas in
mind I think I probably I favor the
Senate version because it doesn't seem
like we're necessarily moving toward a a
better solution I think the Senate
version which basically says if you show
up you don't have legal counsel for an
involuntary admission it will be
provided it seems like a pretty good
standard
I I my I I could be wrong but I thought
that the witnesses who testified about
on the
non-uh emergency admissions in not
emergency admissions involuntary
admissions I thought said they don't
know whether what HHS does in terms of
trying to seek reimbursement and I don't
I don't know the answer to that question
either although I would say
if they're if they're not taking any
action to seek reimbursement under the
existing law which says that a person
who is not Indigent is required to pay
then they're not complying with with
current law
representative Tripp
thank you Mr chair
uh
A lot's been said uh
so I'm going to add my two cents worths
uh I think
the Senate bill well admirable is a
little open-ended
uh
all you have to do to qualify is not
show up with a
legal counsel to qualify for the uh the
cost of such court appointed attorneys
including Consul and investigative
expert or other services and expense
approved by the Circuit Court
that's a little open-ended in my mind
and I would believe that uh
the uh amendment by representative Lynn
closes that door a little bit so I I'm
in favor of the uh the amendment thank
you
uh representative kuta
thank you Mr chairman so I was a bit
confused so I did just open up the
current statue and currently it says the
client or person sought to be admitted
shall pay the cost of the legal services
in connection with hearings held under
this chapter
if the client or person sought to be
admitted is unable to pay the court show
a point to member of the New Hampshire
legal council who shall be compensated
as determined by the court so currently
as it stands today the person is
required to pay so I don't
think if I just want to make sure I'm
understanding correctly your Amendment
isn't changing really what the current
process is that much it's just changing
the office that's paying it that's
correct that that the current law is as
I just said that if that in these
proceedings you are required to pay
unless you can't pay and nothing in
either my Amendment or representative
Smith's Amendment changes that it's the
Senate bill
as we as we got it from the Senate that
makes that change
one further question of my name
so the way that it currently is today it
doesn't even say anything about if if
they can't determine it so it would seem
like your amendment is actually offering
an alternate course some flexibility for
if somebody if they're unable to
determine it because otherwise right now
you have to make the determination under
the current law the way it stands today
so is this offering more flexibility
well it's I I suppose in some sense yes
I think the the the the thing that we
don't really know is what is HHS doing I
mean they have a contract with with us
you know for some people to provide uh
these Services what do they do that I
assume if they're following the law they
are trying to collect uh from people who
who are able to reimburse but we don't
you know I I guess I would assume they
are following the law
so but but this my proposed amendment or
representative Smith's proposed
amendment makes no changes to that
aspect of it
other comments
all right
um
are we I guess what I would do is what I
would do is this um
in light of the comments that have been
made by both representative Smith and
um uh representative Stapleton I'm I am
not going to I'm going to withdraw my
proposed amendment and I am going to
move Amendment
2023-1676h which is Representatives
representative Smith cement
excuse me
um Mr chair while you are the chair
you cannot move my Amendment unless I
bring the amendment to the committee
um because this this amendment
I have it here I have all the copies
here it has not you know I
and so
I would have to decide in fact if I
would not just have informed people that
I have this amendment but actually
introduce it to the committee
and
um
I am in a dilemma
and I think I know how it will end up
um my dilemma is that my preference
is the bill as it came to us from the
Senate as amended that is my preference
I've felt very strongly that not
doubting your intention in any way but
that your amendment was not
appropriate
primarily but not exclusively because of
section two
I have problems
with section one of your Amendment
nonetheless
what I proposed to do
was recognizing that I don't live in a
perfect world
and that I am have never been part of
the my way or the highway group I have
always believed and compromise both
Within
my political caucus but certainly
within the full body of the committee or
the house
so
my dilemma is do I introduce it or not
and my conclusion is
because of my respect for the chair and
his intention and because of my
commitment
to
um
to compromise
uh
with conflicting views that yes I will
present Amendment 1676.
to the committee I'm happy now to
officially
pass it out but I want to make clear to
everybody
that
I acknowledge that I personally believe
the bill
as it came to us from the Senate
is better than this
but I will not let the perfect be the
enemy of the less perfect so so if
that's a motion to introduce this bill I
I would second it
all right
all right so so it's moved by
representative Smith and seconded by
representative Edwards and
oh Edward oh since I will second it then
I'm sorry I will second oh an alternate
can second is that the rule I've I've
learned I've learned two things in the
last in the last five minutes I learned
something the last few seconds okay
and what's the motion chair what's the
motion it's uh it's a motion to uh
otpa with uh representative Smith's
Amendment uh 2023-1676h
that's been moved and and seconded
um
uh representative Smith is there
anything further that you would like to
say
I I don't I think I've made the
I've made the point
um I'm not happy with this but I don't
expect to be happy all the time
well I I guess what I what I what I
would say is that first of all I want to
thank I want to thank representative
Smith and I appreciate very much your
your sort of spirit of bipartisanship I
know we have
differences among the committee members
on this
I I guess as and I don't want to be
repeating myself and I apologize if I am
but I guess
my sense is that in the real world of
how how this amendment would operate
there aren't there aren't likely to be
very many circumstances in which
if any of us were the judge
we would disagree as to what should
happen in a particular case
um I guess I
um
you know I agree that there will be many
cases as judge king pointed out where
there will be
where it'll be an easy decision to say
the person is Indigent and it will be uh
and it may well be an easy decision to
say that the person doesn't have any
ability to repay but
there that's not all the cases and it
shouldn't be
the law
that somebody who can repay
um even if it turns out to be on an
installment basis or whatever is somehow
gets a free ride where somebody who
is you know in the
it is retains brings their own counsel
with them to the hearing
um
doesn't get a free ride that just seems
to me to be fundamentally unfair and so
that's the that's the basis upon which
uh I I propose uh I propose the
amendment and I I hope you'll support it
any other comments
yes representative Stapleton
just for my clarification and
understanding is this motion to just
bring the amendment to admit and
consider or are we going to actually
vote on
um representative Smith's Amendment now
we will we will be voting on
representative Smith's Amendment and
just again for for to make it absolutely
clear representative Smith's Amendment
is exactly the same as my Amendment
except that it there's no section two
there's my section two of my amendment
is is removed
do we have to consider your Amendment as
first introduced before we consider hers
no I withdrew my I withdrew my Amendment
so it was this it's only representative
Smithsonian thank you so I think unless
anybody else has any eye to comment I
think we're ready to call the roll
um so I'd ask the clerk to please uh
call the roll uh representative
so
the motion then would be
OTP a
um as amended by 1676
and the first vote would be on the
amendment
yes that's correct that's correct so the
first vote will be on the amendment and
I would ask the clerk to call the rule
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Roy
rep Andrews YES Prep testerman
rep Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep
Grayson yes kirkutabouts yes rep Edwards
yes
rep Smith
repore again
yes
rep Delorenzo
no
rep Kenny yes
rep Brennan no
Brett Macbeth no
rep jamana no
crap eaten no
rep Rosner no repturer
no
chairman Lynn yes
Amendment passes 13-7
. and
um now we're on to the main uh motion
anybody have anything further they want
to say on the main motion before we
call the roll
seeing none I'd ask the clerk to please
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Roy yes
rep Andrews yes rep testerman
rep Stapleton YES Prep trip yes rep
Grayson
tab votes yes rep Edwards yes reps reps
meth
yes
rep Oregon no
rep dilorenzo yes
rep Kenny yes
Brett Brennan
yes
Brett Macbeth no
rept your Mana yes
rep Eden yes
rep Rosner no
rept her
yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 17-3
right all right um
representative Smith uh since it was
Europe I'm more than happy to write the
report if you'd like but if you want to
write it the you were the author of the
amendment
thank you
I would yield to your Superior abilities
thank you very much even though I'm sure
that that is in any way more anyway
wanted but I appreciate your will
will there be a will there be
will there be a Minority Report
when is it due it's literally due like
no yeah because I might it's got you got
to get it I you got to get it in like by
noon time literally because we this is a
this is a fast track bill it's got to go
to finance
so if you want to write a Minority
Report you're fine I'm happy to have it
but you got to get it to me by noon time
I'm I'm hoping not to be the person who
writes a report but could the does the
alternative motion have to be itl or
could it just be OTP without the
amendment to
yeah I mean you can you have somebody
you could I think you can say and there
in a Minority Report what you favor but
you got to have it you got to have it to
me by noontime that's you know so some
are you going to write a Minority Report
I was hoping to get out of it but uh
well it's I I mean it doesn't have to be
a Minority Report but if there's going
to be I'd like to know who's going to
write it let's just
I mean I could write it I could write a
simple one saying that the minority
believed that what the Senate sent over
is preferable to the amendment all right
so you're volunteering representative
okay all right
England
okay
and
Oregon all right all right um is there
anything else any other business that we
uh
that we need to deal with
um have we received any Senate
um bills for where we would have to
concur no we have not yet I have not
received any yet thank you and do you
know what your what your procedure will
be if and when we do receive any no but
I want to talk to you about that thank
you I want to get your guidance on it
for sure
um so you know what the only thing I
would the only thing I would say is
um uh sometime we've got a fair number
of bills that we've retained some time
thinking about a meeting since the
speaker said we can do this and we can
at least start in June I'm thinking that
sometime in early June we might have a
meeting and I'll send out when I think
what I thought I would do is send out a
an email to everybody and say Here's a
few dates that I think it would work let
me know what you what works for you and
then we'll figure out a date that you
know that seems to work for the most
people and take it from there
that sound good
great all right thank you everybody I'd
like to thank all of the I think we have
six yes out of our 20 members six are
substitutes and I want to thank all six
for their thank you very much due
diligence